je suis lna je suis designer et c'est la
nature le vivant qui m'inspire je vous
propose un voyage dans le monde de la
nuit
ce monde parfois étranges et qui fait
peur je vous invite à aller à la
rencontre d'une espèce qui n'est ni un
animal ni un végétal je vous présente ce
champignon martien tout vert alors la
journée il va ressembler à une pleurotes
et la nuit il va s'éclairer ou plus
exactement vous allez le voir ce éclairé
la nuit parce que lui brille
continuellement ce champignon et
bioluminescence la bioluminescence
existe chez d'autres espèces comme chez
la luciole
le ver luisant et dans le monde marin
chez le champignon il ya à peu près 60
espèces bioluminescente depuis que j'ai
découvert cette bioluminescence je suis
fasciné je passe des heures à l'observer
et elle bouge elle va commencer dans le
mycélium la racine du champignon et elle
va ensuite se concentrer dans le pied et
les lamelles du champignon je vais vous
montrer un film d'à peu près de moins
d'une minute qui reprend une semaine de
croissance des champignons en accéléré
chaque prise de vue a duré à peu près un
quart d'heure vingt minutes pour
reproduire ce que vous verrez une fois
les yeux habitués au noir alors au tout
début la première caméra est en plongée
et va filmer un début de croissance de
champignons avec une bioluminescence
concentré qui va bouger en fonction des
soubresauts de la croissance du
champignon elle va ensuite se concentrer
dans le pied et les lamelles les
chapeaux eux qui ne seront pas
luminescents vous venir tout recouvrir
ensuite la deuxième caméra qui filme de
côté va permettre de voir la lumière
dans les lamelles ensuite le champignon
une fois qu'il aura atteint sa maturité
va se recroqueviller va mourir va moisir
est nouvelle
souche de champignon va pousser alors
cette bioluminescence et la réaction est
le produit d'une réaction chimique le
champignon ils poussent sur du bois dur
du chêne dû être dufresne et grâce à la
lignine qu'il va puiser dans ce bois ce
substrat sont terro il va produire de la
lucie ferraz cette enzyme va réagir
wass oxydé au contact de l'oxygène de
l'air et va produire la bioluminescence
il va transformer l'énergie chimique en
énergie lumineuse sous forme de photos
noir
on ne connaît toujours pas les raisons
de cette bioluminescence il ya plusieurs
hypothèses qui sont testés il peut
vouloir attirer des insectes pour
disperser ces sports ces graines il peut
vouloir repousser des prédateurs pour
éviter de se faire manger comme
certaines espèces il ya une troisième
hypothèse celle que je préfère la
lumière servirait à attirer des insectes
qui se nourrissent du même bois qui vont
y pondre des larves qui vont des
composés ce bois et qui vont le rendre
plus comestibles aux champignons en
travaillant sur ce champignon j'ai eu
envie de partager cette découverte et je
me suis demandé comment en tant que
designer jeu pouvait permettre à
d'autres cette rencontre en 2013
substrat est né c'est une veilleuse
on peut donc cultiver sa lumière chez
soi naturellement j'ai imaginé une bulle
qui va reproduire les conditions de la
foire et c'est le champignon qui m'a
dicté la forme qui m'a transmis son
cahier des charges en fonction de ses
besoins pour permettre pour exemple par
exemple la forme de la boule qui va
permettre la condensation et qui va
faire retomber l'eau dont il a besoin
pour permettre à ce champignon de vivre
de pousser en appartement vous devez lui
offrir le gîte et le couvert
alors le gîte c'est cette bulle qui
permet la condensation qui chaude et
humide et pour le nourrir vous devez le
saupoudrer de sciure 7,6 urgent de les
stériliser pour éviter à d'autres
champignons de s'installer et pour qu'on
évite d'assister à un combat de
champignons
j'ai remplacé la mousse la mousse de la
forêt qui pousse pas en intérieur par
une mousse aquatique qui elle va
relâcher de l'oxygène et va nettoyer
l'eau stagnante
il a fallu un an pour mettre substrat au
point parce que travailler avec le
vivant sait aussi s'adapter au rythme du
vivant le champignon mais trois mois a
poussé donc chaque essai mais trois mois
alors à travers substrat l'important
pour moi c'est de partager de faire
découvrir ce qui existe se dire que la
nouvelle technologie dont on a besoin
existe déjà et qu'elle pousse à côté de
nous depuis 2013 certains ont déjà tenté
l'aventuré ont adopté un champignon chez
eux ils vont bien les champignons et les
propriétaires et donc j'échange toujours
avec eux sur leurs découvertes sur
l'ordre sur leurs observations et j'ai
même des nouvelles d'un champignon qui
est parti en vacances à la mer avec son
nouvel ami pendant ce projet j'ai
rencontré celui qui est aujourd'hui mon
partenaire didier blackie et chercheur
en mycologie et en microbiologie et on
travaille ensemble sur la suite de ce
projet là imaginez vous la ville de
demain uniquement éclairé par des
champignons
alors il existe déjà des recherches sur
la bioluminescence sur l'éclairage à
partir de plancton et de bactéries
bioluminescente mais aucune n'est fait
sur la bioluminescence fongiques pour
développer cet éclairage du futur de
demain on travaille depuis un an sur
plusieurs hypothèses où travaillent sur
la souche du champignon qu'on peut
booster on va travailler sur
l'environnement du champignon en lui
rajoutant de l'oxygène où on lui
proposant d'autres substrat d'autres
bois on va travailler sur l'enzyme en
reproduisant la réaction chimique
et puis on peut aussi aller chercher
d'autres exemples naturel comme par
exemple cet escargot marin qui a une
très faible lumière mais dans la
coquille augmente considérablement cette
lumière et donc mon idée est de
m'inspirer de la structure et de la
matière de cette coquille pour faire une
lan
plus j'observe plus je me dis qu'il ya à
prendre en travaillant avec ce
champignon en étudiant d'autres espèces
j'ai découvert la symbiose des animaux
des plantes des champignons vont
s'associer vont céder pour se
transmettre des informations des besoins
les abeilles vont manger vont se nourrir
de pollen et voor polliniser le bol et
un autre champignon lui va chercher des
minéraux dans le sol pour un arbre et va
profiter du sucre issu de la
photosynthèse de celui-ci ou même nous
qui logeront dans nos intestins une
quantité inimaginable de bactéries qui
nous aident à digérer la nature nous
offre tout ce dont on a besoin
nous sommes aussi la nature et si on la
laisse s'exprimer
on peut échanger avec elle on connaît
aujourd'hui seulement 15 % des espèces
qui existent et elles ont une sérieuse
avance en recherche et développement sur
nous la symbiose c'est peut-être ça le
plus gros process a copié dans la nature
en observant avec cette notion en créant
en inventant en se posant cette question
qu'est-ce que je modifie
qu'est-ce que je donne en échange et à
qui on peut réintégrer ce cercle
symbiotique et on aura peut-être la
surprise qu'une autre espèce nous offre
quelque chose
moi je suis persuadé que ce cadeau
viendra d'un champignon au xviiie siècle
voltaire disait cultivez votre jardin
aujourd'hui on peut cultiver sa lumière
alors rêvons observons et échangent ou
merci